I have mixed feelings about both of them
actually the trans fat man I actually
commented on an op-ed piece in The New
York Times so I'm on record as saying
and it was the way it was explained to
me by people in the health department is
that they were doing this because they
could do it I don't think the trans fats
are the biggest problem in the American
food supply but there they are not very
good to eat they're not helpful and they
can easily be gotten rid of easily be
gotten rid of they don't have a taste
they don't have a flavor they can be
replaced there are ways to replace them
it's not even very expensive to replace
and there's no reason for them to be in
the food supply at all so in that sense
I'm not opposed to the trans fat ban the
foie gras one is much more complicated
because if you're going to eat animals
in general you're going to they're all
going to be killed any animal that you
eat is going to be killed and so the
question is then how do you kill them
and in the case of a foie gras and
feeding ducks the Ducks don't look very
tortured to me or the geese don't look
very tortured they really don't and I
think I'm much more concerned about the
way mammalian animals are raised if I'm
going to be concerned about these things
having seen pregnant sows in South
grades that would be place where I would
start
you